y escombros esparcidos por severodonezk
mientras las tropas rusas y ucranianas
luchan en las calles por la estratégica
ciudad a pesar del avance de su enemigo
las autoridades ucranianas dicen que su
ejército sigue resistiendo
he escuchado personalmente muchas veces
que severo de un yesca fue ocupada que
el ejército ruso la ha tomado por
completo así que quiero decirles que no
que no ha sido tomada por completo cruz
ya tiene alrededor del 70 por ciento
ahora ya los hemos hecho retroceder
aproximadamente 20 por ciento
la captura de severodonezk ponemos q a
un paso de controlar la totalidad de
lugansk es una de las dos provincias que
conforman el donbass una región que
ahora se ha convertido en el objetivo
clave de la guerra para las fuerzas de
vladimir putin
antes de poder reclamar la victoria
sobre lugansk el ejército ruso todavía
tiene que controlar la ciudad del issys
hanks la situación allí es cada vez más
grave
no hay electricidad ni agua lo único que
tenemos es el agua potable gracias a los
bomberos ellos nos traen agua para lavar
una historia similar se vive en la
ciudad de slomianski situada en donestsk
la otra mitad del donbass allí también
se han cortado los suministros básicos
por los bombardeos rusos
en un discurso para conmemorar los 100
días desde el inicio de la guerra el
viernes el presidente vladimir selenski
lanzó un mensaje de esperanza a los
ucranianos ya llevamos 100 días
defendiendo a ucrania la victoria será
nuestra gloria a ucrania gloria a sus
héroes la onu estima que cuatro mil
civiles han muerto desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa mientras que los
funcionarios ucranianos dicen que el
número real de muertos puede ser mucho
mayor